we have to get back into the business of
developing human beings
you know we have a uh
um
we have a desire you know human beings
are now
in such a state of like hyper complexity
where everything is integrated
everything is connected that there is no
individuality there is no original
thought you become an amalgamation of
everything that you've heard and been
exposed to but you really do nothing
right
like the jury's out like wake up do hard
work learn about yourself turn the
off like meditate like you know eat a
carrot every now and then like
and and life is going to be pretty good
for you
um doesn't mean it's going to be easy
but you'll have the built-in tools
and you'll begin to learn about your
higher self
and you know people can say like you
know this is like
magic or whatever but like there is like
i don't care you're in worry like you
got the spidey senses what is that what
is that
what is that thing what is meaning right
what is this what is this thing meaning
that we all have we're all going to
answer that question at some point in
our life whether you get hit by a you
know a skateboarder like and whack your
head in the curb or you die in combat or
you
you know eat yourself to death like
you're all going to face those those
things and to me the hero's journey is
the journey of learning about yourself
and using those tools to overcome the
external circumstances that you face
and so
like over the 41 days like we have you
know that
every guy walks at least 80 miles in the
program just to meals they'll spend 22
days in the wilderness they won't eat a
piece of sugar they won't eat dairy they
won't eat they won't have juice
they will only eat meat vegetables salt
water and black coffee and
they will learn to meditate they'll get
into an ice tank every single day they
will start their day with mindfulness
they'll read books they'll go through
leadership courses they'll learn to shoe
horses ride horses they'll learn to see
themselves you know working with wild
mustangs they'll be put in very
dangerous situations all these are just
tools to shift focus from a person that
is always looking out for answers
to a person that is looking in for
answers and then using those answers to
then change the material world around
them with their choices that are
authentically theirs and that's called
purpose and when you
start to do that
there's always a dragon that steps out
right in front of you
right the dragon steps out in front of
you and and then you find out how much
you really want it because everything is
designed today to keep you from knowing
what you are like social media doesn't
exist if you're not there
the internet doesn't exist if you're not
there you are the energy source that
feeds your own demise
so so you give
your energy to feed your own destruction
and then you complain about the very
thing that you're feeding
when it's always you
you're the one i always tell people like
oh god i like the guys like the twitters
and this and then you know whatever it's
like
it's like oh god he did but it's not
there if you're not there
you feed it you are feeding and you are
clothing and you are arming your own
captors
you are and everything is designed to
keep you
sound asleep consume consume consumes
consume yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum
yum yum food
let's get something you know everything
is designed to fulfill these physical
desires
that then override you from searching
from the real energy source that the
people that are aware know of they know
i need you to feed what i'm building
you will serve serve serve as the cog
in a gigantic organism and you will give
your energy
40 50 years of it you get your little
plaque thanks for bob employee of the
month and and
and then what you go down to south
florida and you sit there
and you just wait
your car you're sitting in the same
traffic yeah maybe it's a ferrari so
what you're in the same traffic
and maybe you get a little bit of better
beef
you know maybe this one was massaged by
50 japanese ladies or whatever right it
doesn't matter
it doesn't matter because then the fear
starts to build
and then that clock just starts going
and next thing you know what are they
doing they're like
ah it's too late
it's too late